Générique
...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle année
dans "Parlement hebdo".
- Kathia Gilder:
Pour cette première
de l'année, nous accueillons
Erwan Balanant.
Vous êtes député
MoDem du Finistère.
Merci d'être avec nous.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On parlera
du baptême du feu
pour Gabriel Attal
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Il a eu ses premières
questions d'actualité
au gouvernement.
On reviendra sur les annonces
d'Emmanuel Macron
lors de sa conférence de presse.
Le président
a annoncé des mesures
pour "réussir
le réarmement civique
de la France".
L'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
est à l'ordre du jour
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Eric Dupond-Moretti
a été auditionné
sur le projet de loi
qui vise à inscrire
la liberté des femmes
de recourir
à l'IVG dans la Constitution.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'était la première séance
de questions au gouvernement
pour Gabriel Attal,
nouveau Premier ministre.
Pas de coup d'éclat
particulier,
mais plusieurs moments forts.
- A l'Assemblée,
pour le plus jeune Premier
ministre de la Ve République,
tout commence
par une standing ovation.
Première séance de questions
au gouvernement
pour Gabriel Attal:
il cherche à imposer
sa marque.
- Les Français traversent
de très grandes difficultés.
Il y a des Français
qui doutent,
des Français qui souffrent,
des Français
en colère et des Français
qui n'y croient plus.
Je ne tomberai jamais
dans le fatalisme
qui consiste à penser
que les problèmes
des Français
ne peuvent pas être réglés.
- Dans l'attente
d'une nouvelle vague
de nominations,
les bancs des ministres
sont en partie vide.
Gabriel Attal
est déjà la cible
de la gauche.
- Ceci n'est pas un remaniement.
C'est un effondrement.
Artisans du malheur
des Français
depuis sept ans
et Premier ministre
depuis sept jours
d'un gouvernement
que vous n'avez pas
choisi,
vous étiez minoritaires
en 2023
et vous le serez en 2024.
- Je ne regarde pas d'où
les gens viennent,
mais où ils veulent aller.
- C'est la fin
du "en même temps"
et la cohabitation assumée
avec la droite dure.
Après la préférence
nationale, voici
la préférence de Sarkozy.
- Je préfère travailler
avec Rachida Dati
et Catherine Vautrin qu'avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon, voilà.
- Gabriel Attal
a décidé de prendre
son temps pour préparer
son discours
de politique générale.
Mais il ne veut
prendre aucun risque.
Il ne se soumettra pas au vote
de confiance
de l'Assemblée nationale.
- Kathia Gilder:
Erwan Balanant,
vous avez observé
les premiers pas
de Gabriel Attal
comme Premier ministre.
Ca fait du bien
d'avoir un profil politique?
- Erwan Balanant:
Madame Elisabeth Borne
était aussi
politique,
mais dans un autre style.
Gabriel Attal a une facilité...
C'est un tribun
moderne, jeune,
avec une aisance
dans le combat politique
et dans la joute politique.
Je pense que ça peut
être un vrai atout.
On a besoin d'expliquer
un certain nombre
de choses.
On a besoin d'expliquer
les bonnes choses
que l'on a faites depuis six ans.
Je suis frappé
par tout un tas de mesures
qui ont préservé
les Français
durant cette période
de Covid,
cette période
de bouclier tarifaire,
toutes les réformes
que nous avons mises
en place qui ont permis
à la France
d'avoir un taux de chômage
historiquement bas.
Gabriel Attal
a cette pugnacité,
cette combativité
qui nous fera du bien.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Sa nomination
ne va pas changer la donne
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Il n'aura pas de majorité
absolue
dans l'hémicycle.
- Erwan Balanant:
Ca
ne changera pas d'un point
de vue
de l'équilibre des forces.
Maintenant,
Gabriel Attal a l'avantage
d'avoir été un parlementaire
qui a siégé.
Elisabeth Borne
était parlementaire,
mais elle n'avait pas siégé
à l'Assemblée.
Il connaît les rouages.
Il sait comment négocier.
Il sait comment on peut emporter
certaines majorités.
Il faut rappeler
que sur la séquence
qui vient de se passer,
des 18 mois
depuis l'élection,
on a passé
plus de 50 textes,
dont 21 textes
à l'unanimité.
C'est possible
d'avoir des majorités
de projet.
C'était une des ambitions
de madame Borne.
On retient les 49.3,
mais c'était juste
quatre textes budgétaires
dont le texte
sur les retraites.
Les autres textes
sont tous passés
sans le 49.3.
- Kathia Gilder:
Gabriel Attal a nommé
un gouvernement plutôt
marqué à droite
avec Rachida Dati,
Catherine Vautrin.
Votre collègue du MoDem,
Jean-Louis Bourlanges,
aurait préféré
que le MoDem soutienne
ce gouvernement.
- Erwan Balanant:
C'était une option...
Mais la réalité,
c'est que l'on a deux
personnalités
nouvelles qui rentrent
au gouvernement.
Il n'y a qu'une
de ces deux personnalités
qui vient des LR.
Catherine Vautrin
a depuis longtemps quitté
les LR.
Il y a des gens
qui sont déjà
dans Renaissance
comme monsieur Darmanin.
C'est vrai qu'ils viennent
de droite,
mais il y a aussi des gens
dans cet hémicycle
qui viennent de gauche.
Jean-Louis Bourlanges
a posé une question
avec sa grande expérience.
C'est: quel va être le programme
politique?
C'est ce que l'on attend
avec impatience.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pour l'instant,
il n'y a qu'un ministre MoDem.
Le compte n'y est pas,
pour le MoDem,
pour l'instant,
pour être représenté
dans l'exécutif?
- Erwan Balanant:
Je n'aime pas parler
de compte.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous souhaitez un rééquilibrage?
- Erwan Balanant: On a parlé
de rééquilibrage audacieux.
Oui, il faut rééquilibrer,
ne serait-ce
que pour être en capacité
à aller chercher
des majorités
avec les sociaux-démocrates
ou les écologistes, parfois.
Sur certains sujets,
on doit y arriver.
- Kathia Gilder:
Amélie Ouéda-Castéra s'est
empêtrée dans une polémique
sur la scolarisation
de ses enfants dans le privé.
Est-ce que pour vous,
avec une telle polémique,
la ministre
de l'Education peut
encore être légitime à son poste?
- Erwan Balanant:
D'abord, je pense
que ce sont des choix
personnels
de famille.
Aux dernières nouvelles,
l'école libre,
en France, privée,
n'est pas hors-la-loi.
Un ministre peut faire ce choix.
Parfois,
on a vu que des pourfendeurs
de ces systèmes
mettaient aussi
leurs enfants
dans des écoles privées.
Arrêtons la chasse aux sorcières.
Après, il y a eu
une grosse maladresse.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Certains parlent
de mensonges
sur les justifications.
-
Erwan Balanant:
Je ne pense pas
que ce soit un mensonge.
C'est par sincérité
et par envie
de bien faire,
par envie de réinventer
ce qu'était un souvenir.
Elle l'a dit.
Est-ce qu'on va lui en vouloir?
Est-ce que lui en vouloir
fera avancer
la cause de l'Education nationale?
C'est un des axes
principaux sur lesquels
nous devons réfléchir.
Il faut lui faire confiance.
Lui faire un procès
sans arrêt,
ça ne va pas faire
avancer cette cause.
- Kathia Gilder:
Il ne risque pas d'y
avoir un dialogue
de sourds
avec les personnels
de l'Education nationale?
- Erwan Balanant:
Non,
parce que son équipe
va être complétée.
Elle aura des gens
pour l'accompagner
sur ces sujets.
Il n'y
a pas de raison
que l'on n'avance pas
sur ces questions.
Il y a un Premier
ministre maintenant
bien imprégné de ces sujets.
Ca doit être un des points
saillants
de cette séquence.
On devra retenir
que l'on a fait beaucoup
pour l'Education nationale.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il y a une échéance importante
pour Gabriel Attal,
c'est le 30 janvier,
date de son discours
de politique générale.
Est-ce que ce discours
sert
à quelque chose?
Emmanuel Macron a déjà
dessiné la suite
du quinquennat.
Qu'attendez-vous de ce discours?
- Erwan Balanant:
Ce n'est pas la même chose.
Le discours du président
est un discours
plus général.
Là, on n'a pas encore parlé
des décisions
à prendre pour les temps
qui viennent.
Comment Gabriel Attal
va-t-il gouverner?
Ensuite, il y a la déclinaison
de certains sujets,
sur des sujets importants
pour les Français
comme le logement, la santé,
l'Education nationale...
Il y a un sujet important,
qui englobe tout,
c'est la transition écologique.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il veut gouverner vite
par circulaire et par décret.
Vous craignez qu'il contourne
le Parlement?
- Erwan Balanant:
C'est difficile
de contourner le Parlement.
C'est le coeur de la démocratie.
Il ne pourra pas contourner cela.
Il n'a pas envie de le faire.
Il est parlementaire dans l'âme.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous pensez qu'il manque
de courage?
- Erwan Balanant: Non.
Les règles mathématiques
de cette répartition
sont là.
C'est comme ça.
On est en majorité relative.
Ce n'est pas le Premier
ministre
qui l'est.
Ce ne sera pas
le dernier
à être en majorité
relative
dans ce pays.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le président
a tenu cette semaine
une conférence
de presse
pour dessiner la suite
de son quinquennat.
Il y a eu des annonces
sur l'école,
la famille.
Il a parlé
d'un réarmement civique
et démographique de la France.
- Sans surprise,
au Sénat, les oppositions
ne sont pas convaincues
par le chef
de l'Etat.
Sa prestation est jugée loin
des préoccupations
des Français par le sénateur
Ian Brossat.
- J'ai vu qu'il était loin
des préoccupations
des Français.
- Même son de cloche
pour le chef
de file des socialistes au Sénat.
Patrick Kanner dit voir
dans cette conférence
de presse un exercice
d'autosatisfaction.
- Le président m'a rassuré.
Le pays va bien.
L'ascenseur social fonctionne.
Nos services publics
ont les moyens
de remplir leur mission.
J'ai sans doute été distrait.
Pour moi, la réalité
était toute autre.
L'Education nationale
est fragilisée.
L'hôpital public s'effondre.
La France compte désormais
près de 5 millions
de pauvres.
- Parmi la liste
d'annonces du chef
de l'Etat: l'expérimentation
de l'uniforme
à l'école, un nouveau
congé de naissance
et un plan
pour la fertilité,
ou encore le doublement
de l'enseignement civique.
Le sénateur François
Patriat a soutenu
ces mesures.
- Le président a dit
qu'il voulait faire
des républicains.
C'est le rôle de la famille,
de l'école,
de l'entreprise,
de la vie quotidienne.
Il était bon de le rappeler.
Il faut rappeler
que dans son mode
de vie, dans son respect
vis-à-vis
des autres,
on a besoin de redresser
la barre.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le président
de la République
a centré ses annonces
sur l'école,
la famille, l'autorité
pour que "la France
reste la France".
Est-ce que ce discours
conservateur correspond
à vos valeurs?
On est loin des valeurs du MoDem.
- Erwan Balanant:
Si vous le prenez
comme ça, oui.
Mais j'ai un peu
approfondi le sujet.
J'ai posé des questions
à certaines personnes
que je connais,
qui sont politisées
sans être dans la mécanique.
On m'a dit:
"En quoi la famille
est nécessairement
une valeur de droite?"
L'école, c'est une valeur
de gauche, aussi.
Je n'aime pas l'idée de réarmer.
Je préférerais que l'on parle
de "réenchanter l'école".
En quoi cette idée
serait une idée
de droite?
On dit qu'on va faire
en sorte de redonner
du travail aux gens,
de donner
plus de valeur aux salaires.
On dit
que l'on va permettre
à tout le monde d'acquérir
les savoirs fondamentaux.
En quoi cela est-il de droite?
- Kathia Gilder:
L'école est un sujet
que vous connaissez bien.
Emmanuel Macron
a annoncé une refonte
de l'instruction civique,
notamment l'instauration
de la tenue unique
dans une centaine
d'établissements.
Pour vous, ce type
d'annonce permet-il
de refonder l'école
et de résoudre
les problèmes actuels?
- Erwan Balanant:
Vous savez comment fonctionne
notre monde médiatique.
On a besoin de points d'accroche.
C'est bien, d'expérimenter
et d'essayer l'uniforme.
Pourquoi pas.
J'ai la conviction
que ça
ne va pas sauver l'école.
Il y a une prise
en compte de ce sujet
par toute la société,
qui comprend
que l'école est prioritaire.
Réenchanter la vie
scolaire, réenchanter
la réussite...
C'est ça, aussi.
Il y a des enfants
issus de milieux
très populaires.
Il faut qu'ils puissent
réussir aussi.
C'est ça qu'il faut montrer.
J'ai plein d'exemples.
On a des collaborateurs
que l'on croise
à l'Assemblée
qui ont des diplômes
très élevés, mais pas seulement.
J'ai une collaboratrice
qui a commencé
avec un BEP.
Elle était dans un milieu
difficile.
Elle a réussi, par l'école,
à devenir attachée parlementaire,
puis membre d'un cabinet.
C'est ça, le réenchantement.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le président
de la République
a aussi confirmé
la baisse d'impôts de 2
milliards d'euros
pour les classes moyennes en 2025.
Est-ce que c'est le moment
d'annoncer
des baisses de recettes,
compte tenu
de l'état de nos finances
publiques?
Comment on les finance?
-
Erwan Balanant:
C'est ce que l'on essaye
de pousser,
au MoDem,
c'est une répartition
plus juste.
On veut peut-être
faire contribuer
des classes supérieures qui,
aujourd'hui, peuvent
le faire.
- Kathia Gilder:
Donc un impôt
sur les plus riches?
- Erwan Balanant:
Je n'aime pas ce terme.
Dès que l'on s'amuse
à définir la richesse...
Certains se sont pris
les pieds
dans le tapis, à cause de cela.
Mais on peut trouver
des recettes nouvelles.
On peut trouver
des choses pour taxer
les superprofits.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ca n'a pas été retenu.
- Erwan Balanant:
Non,
mais on a des gens
pugnaces et déterminés.
On pourrait avancer.
Les classes
moyennes méritent
d'avoir leurs impôts qui baissent.
Elles sont souvent
dans des situations difficiles
tout en travaillant
et en ayant
des familles à nourrir.
Il y a un sentiment d'injustice.
Il n'y a pas de grandes
démocraties
sans les classes moyennes.
Sociologiquement, ça n'existe pas.
On a besoin d'une
classe moyenne
qui a la conviction que,
pour ses enfants,
si tout le monde
travaille, s'il
y a une volonté
de réussir, la situation
va s'améliorer dans la famille.
La répartition
de l'effort peut
être vue à la marge, certainement.
On avait parlé de tranche d'impôt.
Cela permettrait
de lisser la répartition.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le président
a parlé de la loi immigration.
Il a défendu la suppression
de certaines prestations sociales
pour les étrangers
après un certain délai.
Je rappelle
que vous avez voté
contre ce projet
de loi immigration.
Espérez-vous
qu'il soit censuré
par le Conseil constitutionnel
la semaine prochaine?
- Erwan Balanant:
J'avais fait une liste
de 30 dispositifs
qui pourraient
être censurés.
On va voir.
Ca fait beaucoup,
mais le texte
est très dense.
Oui, j'espère qu'un
certain nombre
de choses seront censurées.
Ce n'est pas le texte
que l'on voulait.
Tout le monde
est conscient
que ce n'est pas le texte initial.
On avait un bon
texte au départ
et c'est dommage
qu'il y ait eu
cette séquence
et ces coups politiques
de la gauche
et de l'extrême droite,
qui ont mené à ce mauvais texte.
Il ne sert à rien,
en l'état actuel
des choses.
Il va être retoqué.
Il y a des dispositifs
sur lesquels
on va devoir revenir.
Les travailleurs
sans-papiers
dans les métiers
en tension, ce texte-là,
il n'est ni fait, ni à faire.
- Kathia Gilder:
Emmanuel Macron
veut réarmer l'école.
C'est un terme
que vous n'aimez pas.
Il veut aussi un réarmement
démographique.
Il incite
les Français à faire
plus d'enfants.
Est-ce que les enfants
sont une arme?
Ca vous choque?
- Erwan Balanant:
Il a pris ce terme
parce que c'est un thème
qu'il a repris
pour le réarmement civique...
- Kathia Gilder:
Comment vous comprenez
ce réarmement?
-
Erwan Balanant:
Ce n'est pas pour faire
des enfants
une arme.
Mais notre modèle
social fonctionne
sur un modèle démographique.
Lorsque ce modèle
démographique ne tient plus,
le modèle social ne tient plus.
C'est de l'économie de base.
- Kathia Gilder:
On a un problème
pour la retraite.
- Erwan Balanant:
Oui,
mais pour le financement
de notre modèle social
dans son ensemble.
On a longtemps eu un taux
de fertilité aujourd'hui,
on a un problème
et sans ce taux
de renouvellement,
il faudra peut-être
avoir des politiques familiales.
Je ne parle pas
de retomber
dans des vieilles politiques
familiales paternalistes.
Aider les femmes
à avoir des enfants,
c'est aider les couples
à avoir enfants.
Il faut aider
les femmes tout au long
de leur carrière
pour qu'elles ne soient
pas les grandes perdantes
de cette politique nataliste.
La différence
de patrimoine créé
par une femme et un homme
sur l'ensemble d'une carrière,
la moyenne, c'est 500.000 euros.
C'est le prix
d'une belle maison
dans nos provinces.
- Kathia Gilder: On va revenir
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Le projet de loi
constitutionnelle destiné
à graver l'IVG
dans la Constitution
a été adopté
en commission des lois.
Le texte sera
examiné fin janvier
en séance publique.
Il reviendra
au Sénat
en février avant d'être soumis
au congrès.
C'est ce que souhaite
Emmanuel Macron.
- On a un grand texte de liberté.
Ce n'est pas
tous les jours,
que l'on peut, tous ensemble,
préparer, porter,
voter, un texte de liberté.
Soit on choisit
de chipoter,
mais ce n'est pas
ce que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui,
soit on consacre ce texte,
on va l'inscrire
dans la Constitution,
dans notre Constitution.
Ce sera la première fois
qu'un pays inscrit
dans sa Constitution
cette liberté.
Si j'étais familier,
je vous dirais
que ça a de la gueule.
Mais en tout cas,
ça a beaucoup d'allure.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Vous êtes optimiste, là-dessus?
- Erwan Balanant:
J'espère
qu'on va avoir cette avancée.
C'est une sorte
d'effet de cliquet.
Notre pays dit
qu'on ne reviendra jamais
en arrière là-dessus.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Personne ne veut revenir
en arrière là-dessus.
- Erwan Balanant: Mon oeil.
Quand on voit certains
amendements portés
par certaines
familles politiques
comme les LR et le RN, mon oeil.
Il y a des gens
qui veulent revenir
en arrière.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ca pourrait
être le cas de certains
députés LR,
le désir de revenir en arrière?
- Erwan Balanant: Oui.
Ce texte est le fruit
d'un consensus
avec mon écriture
à l'Assemblée nationale...
- Kathia Gilder:
Le 22 novembre 2022.
- Erwan Balanant:
Ensuite, il y a eu
un texte un peu différent
et un consensus
a été trouvé.
Il faut aller au bout des débats.
Ca va marquer
notre histoire politique.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous étiez impliqué
dans la rédaction
d'un amendement commun
qui avait permis de trouver
un accord transpartisan.
Est-ce que la formulation
telle
qu'elle est retenue vous convient?
Vous souhaitiez
non pas reconnaître
une liberté
mais inscrire le droit
dans la Constitution.
- Erwan Balanant:
Après discussion
avec des
constitutionnalistes,
les deux ont la même
portée effective
et juridique.
Si ce n'est qu'un
problème sémantique,
on ne va pas se faire
des noeuds
au cerveau pour ça.
Par contre,
ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que l'écriture
telle
qu'elle a été faite
sur ce travail
de consensus,
elle est encore mieux.
Je n'avais pas pensé
à l'article 34.
Il y aura un nouvel alinéa
pour l'article 34
de la Constitution.
Cela lui donne
encore plus de force
que l'endroit où on l'avait mis.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'article 34,
c'est le coeur de la loi.
- Erwan Balanant: Oui.
Que ce soit l'article 1
ou le dernier article
de la Constitution,
ils ont tous
la même portée.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Merci, Erwan Balanant,
d'avoir été avec nous.
Merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission.
- Kathia Gilder:
A la semaine prochaine.